of course switching off is easier said
than done
I'm now joined in the studio by Vanna I
chose from the Institute of labor
economics who's done research on the
subject of burnout and I'd like to ask
you first is burn out real as work
really become more stressful
yeah the given the data that we have at
hand I think it's an obvious development
that we're moving away from this that
the physical hazards of the old economy
to this mob psychosocial risks are
including burn out in the modern heavy
creative stressful world of work so this
is a real problem and there also is a
real debate about our policies at a
company level to reduce under level of
stress
there's digitalization made things worse
oh or has it has it taken stress away
well in a way I think given the data
also that was shown in the movie arm you
can definitely see that the intensity of
information and the flow of information
has become faster and more intense so
this is one thing um on the other hand
down digitization is not necessarily bad
thing it also allows for new ways of
flexible responding to certain demands
ie may be responding to something about
you not in the office and also to
interact with your colleague to solve an
urgent problem without going to the
office on the weekend for example yeah
that's an interesting point I just
imagine a top manager sitting at home at
the dinner table with the family the
kids are there and then the phone buzzes
and there's an email she's been waiting
for and she just quickly types an answer
and goes comes back to the to the family
20 years ago she wouldn't be at home
with her family she'd be in the office
waiting for a fax so is that progress or
is it not I would say this is a positive
development because it allows you to be
combined family or private activities
with these business requirements to a
better extent um but at the same time I
think it's also uh there's also the need
for amateur and a bit more more
realistic behavior towards a
digitization not potentially
contributing to further increase let's
say the information overload or do i
establish certain
in principles regarding emails and so
forth
if you look at the figures it looks like
that we're working less in Germany I
think it's roughly three hours less per
week than 25 years ago are we becoming
too soft maybe when it comes to hug I
would not say so
for Putin burger cause I'm the working
time is basically and to say mommy if I
seen more part-time burger so well the
same why has it become more stressed and
well people are expected to work more
with tighter deadlines some productivity
is increasing also the need to be
creative and so subjectively this
current create certain are situations of
stress but only if the resource is and
in the social environment this available
is not favorable to such a development
so there's definitely an issue for
formal policies also for the working
culture at a at a workplace that really
makes a difference our companies big
companies doing something and what are
they doing to reduce stress levels well
I think that the bigger companies are
definitely are in can dispose of better
resources to professionally address
these issues and they can establish a
more formal rules probably but the same
goes also with smaller companies and the
basic thing is the cake is in the eating
so that means in day-to-day practices
also are in terms of explicit or
implicit demands by for example managers
or your boss I think it's been limited
if uhrin sits not so much about what's
written on paper or put somewhere on the
intranet and that makes a difference
when I just from the Institute of labor
economics thank you very much for come
to the studio today you're welcome